good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster the prime minister
will discuss ways to protect women from
violence with the head of the
metropolitan police today
after describing footage of police
breaking up a vigil
in memory of sarah everard as deeply
concerning
this as the government is accused of
rushing through a bill
which labour says will impose
disproportionate controls on
free expression but the conservatives
say
labour is trying to block greater
protections
plenty to discuss with the policing
minister kit mulhouse
and the shadow policing minister sarah
jones shortly
plus is this coming to a city near you
bath launches its own congestion zone
this morning to clean up its air
we speak to a pediatric respiratory
professor
who warns the air pollution poses a huge
threat to children's
health
and tackling racial inequality in music
we'll be joined by the founders of black
lives in music a new organization
on a data-driven mission to explore the
experiences
of black musicians it's monday the 15th
of march
deeply concerned the prime minister will
meet with senior police officers to
discuss
women's safety as the met police faces
criticism
after breaking up a vigil for sarah
everard
we'll be live outside scotland yard as
the police commissioner
defends the force's actions and resists
calls to step down
what has happened makes me more
determined
not less to lead my organization
also ahead a decade at war we report
from syria
where 10 years of conflict have killed
nearly 600 000 people
and forced millions from their homes
hairdressers will open in wales as
primary school pupils return there and
in scotland
as coronavirus restrictions are eased
this morning
the grammy goes to beyonce
and beyonce becomes the most decorated
female act
in grammy's history in a triumphant
awards night
for women and from midweek onwards the
weather will start to settle down with
largely dry conditions but until then
there's still going to be some wet
weather for today i'll have the details
of you later in the programme
[Music]
welcome to sky news breakfast today
boris johnson will meet
senior police officers to discuss
women's safety
as a storm of criticism continues over a
police crackdown
at a vigil for sarah everard the prime
minister said he's deeply concerned
after officers clashed with crowds
gathered to remember
the 33 year old in south london hundreds
of angry protesters
gathered outside new scotland yard
before marching to parliament square
yesterday
with demonstrators chanting shame on you
at offices
metropolitan police commissioner
commissioner dame crested dick
is resisting calls to resign and said
saturday's events
will be reviewed a warning this report
from our political correspondent tom
rayner
does contain some flash photography
commenting for the first time since
these scenes on saturday
the prime minister has said he's deeply
concerned by what took place
and has insisted lessons must be learned
in a statement boris johnson said
today i will chair a meeting of the
government's crime and justice task
force
to look at what further action we need
to take to protect women
and ensure our streets are safe the
death of sarah everard must unite us in
determination to drive out violence
against women and girls
and make every part of the criminal
justice system work to protect and
defend them
[Applause]
[Music]
an independent investigation of the
metropolitan police has been launched
after the home secretary said
the force still had questions to answer
and the mayor of london said he was not
satisfied with the explanations provided
by the commissioner
but as fresh protests were held in
westminster yesterday
cressida dick defended the actions taken
by officers
and insisted she would not resign are
you considering your position
no i'm not what happened to sarah
appalls me as you know i'm the first
woman commissioner i've met
perhaps it appalls me in a way even more
because of that
what has happened makes me more
determined
not less to lead my organization
but the labour mp who represents the
constituency in which the events took
place
says the commissioner's position is
untenable as far as i'm concerned that
the message would have come from from
the top
she is at the top somebody has to take
responsibility
for what has happened and and it should
be it should be the commissioner
the labour leader however said he didn't
want to see the commission
resign and instead demanded more from
government
this week in parliament we start a
policing bill
300 or so pages 170 something clauses
and
almost nothing almost nothing if you can
believe it on violence against women and
girls
the gaping hole in this bill it's why
we'll be voting against it
and a complete missed opportunity by the
government the conservative party
rejects that characterization
accusing sakia stamina of being
disingenuous and trying to block laws
intended to keep people safe
but the weekend's events could yet see
the government face pressure from within
its own party
from back benches who say covid
regulations are the real reason
a peaceful vigil ended like this tom
rayner
sky news westminster
well i'm joined now by the policing
minister kit malt house good morning to
you
and what did you make of events on
saturday evening when you saw those
scenes on your
television screen well along with
everybody else i found it very
distressing and the pictures were
obviously
alarming which is why the home
secretaries asked for this
independent investigation into what
actually
happened so that we can hold the police
accountable which i know they're
happy uh uh to be so um to make sure
that everything
was done in accordance with the rules
look i think we have to reflect on the
fact that
saturday obviously saw unleashing a huge
amount of emotion
and anger not just about the appalling
crime that had occurred but about a
repressed sense
of women's safety um and that that was
in in jeopardy and under threat
and that's what we'll be talking about
with the prime minister this afternoon
to see what more we can do alongside the
other work that we've been doing
um together me and the home secretary
over the last year or so
on this particular issue crested dick
has said that some people have been
armchair critics and that police are
under immense
pressure do you back calls that she
should stand down
no i don't and i do recognize that the
police are in an incredibly difficult
position i mean throughout this pandemic
we've asked them to do a job that
they've never done before and to
stand between uh the public if you like
and this terrible
virus in a way that none of us are used
to and certainly they aren't as well
um and so that very very difficult
position that they're in
needs to be reflected in our
contemplation of of this you know in the
vast majority of cases
uh the police and the public have
managed this situation extremely well
between them this particular
circumstance where emotion was running
naturally extremely high everybody
incredibly
distressed about what had happened and
indeed the police themselves devastated
i know about the implications of this
case that in these circumstances it's
very important
that we get to the detail of what's
happened and that's i think what will
emerge over the next couple of weeks
you say that the police are in a
difficult position they would echo that
because they're saying that simply
they've been there repeatedly called on
by the the home secretary to be tougher
in their enforcement of covid
restriction laws
so they're only being they've only done
as they've been asked to do
well we've all been very focused on uh
suppressing the virus
and it's now more important than ever
that we do so you only have to look in
the newspapers across
europe to see that the virus is
re-emerging in countries
uh in the eu um and some i think italy
contemplating
another national lock down shortly so
we're at a very
powerless moment it's only a few weeks
since the nhs was under
uh significant stress and so we are very
focused on
the home secretary sorry just to
interrupt but do you agree that the home
secretary has
called on the police to be stricter in
their enforcement of covert restrictions
she certainly called on the police and
the public to observe the law
and make sure that maths gatherings are
um avoided and pointed out that they are
illegal um we're obviously not privy to
the detailed operational decisions that
are taken quite rightly so
and that's i think what the uh
investigation of the next couple of
weeks
we'll have a look at to make sure that
the decisions were made in accordance
uh with that kind of protocol and with
the law but look we're all struggling
with what is a very very
difficult situation we totally
understand and i feel it myself the
anger
that has arisen because of this terrible
terrible crime and what we now need to
do
is make sure we're all focused on the
notion of making
our streets as safe as possible for
everybody but particularly for women and
girls
were you aware as an individual of how
widespread
women's experiences of sexual harassment
has been
uh i was and i have to say um
10 years ago or so when i was at city
hall as deputy mayor for policing
to the then mayor boris johnson we
published the first ever
violence against women and girls
strategy in a major global city
focusing on specifically many of the
issues
that people are still sadly raising that
are
you know it seems endemic in parts of
our society and that's why for example
we brought forward the domestic abuse
bill which is reaching the end of its
passage
through the house at the moment which
will significantly enhance our ability
to deal
with domestic violence and abuse and why
we're very focused for example
on the problems we're seeing in rape
convictions and have an end-to-end rape
review
which is currently on the blocks should
be published shortly hopefully
that will renew our efforts to try and
achieve justice for those women
who are victimized in that particular
horrendous crime type so there's been a
huge amount going on for some time
i do understand people's frustration
though that we're not making
as fast progress as perhaps they would
have liked but they should be assured
that there is enormous effort going into
this and that's what we'll be outlining
with the prime minister this afternoon
will sexual harassment be looked at as a
specific crime
well this is obviously one of the issues
that we we're asking for views on
at the moment one of the responses to
this terrible crime to sever
everett's terrible killing uh was for us
to reopen
our call for views um about violence
against women and girls and
we've had something like just in the
last couple of days someone like 64
000 uh people have come online at gov
dot uk
to give us their views about where they
think policy should go into the future
we'll be digesting that over the weeks
to come and be bringing forward a new
violence against women and girls
strategy a refreshed one
later in the year to to really confront
some of these issues
uh labour saying that the excuse me the
police crime and sentencing and courts
bill that's to be debated this week
they're saying that that could lead to
harsher penalties for damaging a statue
than than attacking a woman they've been
quite critical
yeah i'm i have to confess to being
disappointed and a bit confused by the
labour approach because obviously the
bill contains
huge uh um protections for the public
not least
with regard to serious sexual offenders
for example
who will spend a lot longer in jail look
on the monuments thing
uh criminal damage already uh carries a
penalty of up to ten years
in prison uh but it's limited uh to
shorter centers is that the value
of the item is less than five thousand
pounds now that obviously
um uh ignores the emotional uh value or
the symbolic value particularly of
of war memorials and other memorials and
so just removing
uh that anomaly um and it seems unusual
to me that they would
pick that particular issue to focus on
when there's so much more in the bill
not least for example
a serious violence duty which is being
put on local authorities
and health services in an area to work
with the police in identifying the
drivers of violence in their location
and then coming up with a strategy to
deal with it right we we're using this
bill to put everybody shoulder to
shoulder
on violence across the board not just
violence against women and girls
important though that is
but violence in society and for labor to
be voting against this bill just seems
to me confused
what what about in terms of um rights to
to protest some criticism there as well
that this will
disproportionately affect uh people's
right to actually protest on the streets
well again i'm i'm concerned that
they're using this particular moment of
of natural anger
in our country and upset to inflame what
is actually quite
mild uh changes uh to public order
legislation
you know public organization has been in
place since 1986 it hasn't been updated
uh we're removing some anomalies and
loopholes uh in the law we're
implementing a law commission
recommendation around
uh public nuisance and just aligning
conditions on protests that apply at the
moment to marches and processions
onto static uh um protests
so the two are are seen in the same uh
breath
and also taking steps to protect the
operation of our
democracy so that people who try and
prevent members of parliament accessing
uh the house for the purposes of voting
or indeed prevent people attending at
court
um will be stopped from doing so you
know we've seen protests over the last
few years adapt its tactics and we
obviously have to adapt
the legislation in what i think is a
relatively mild way
recognizing that protest and freedom of
speech is absolutely fundamental
to our democracy but it has to be
balanced against the rights of others to
go about their business
and indeed against the operation of our
democracy which is
even more vital in terms of crimes
against women can you see misogyny the
act of misogyny actually becoming
a crime because it isn't at the moment
is it
well as i say street harassment um and
some of the
i mean it's been really distressing to
see some of the episodes that have been
um shared through social media and
in the newspapers over the last few days
and as i say having
having worked on this in the past um it
didn't come as a
surprise to me i have to say but it did
come as a source of anger along with
everybody else
and i think we're all have a duty in
politics
to focus on those issues and see what
more we can do as i say the
call for people's views is open now i
would urge people to go on and share
their anger distress
their personal experience of these
situations so that we can
shape policy into the future and get it
right for everybody
i want to just ask you a final question
about um
astrazeneca and the fact that seven
countries have now suspended
its use um pending at the inquiries
about possible
blood clots as a result of using it um
do you believe that we should now be
looking at the use of of astrazeneca's
because many people have already had
this vaccine
no i don't um and the scientists tell us
that uh all is well
um and that the incidence of these uh
particular problems is
is no greater than you would expect in
the population at large and that these
things naturally occur anyway
obviously the vaccines been through very
very stringent testing before it was
authorized for use we have some of the
highest standards in the world
for medical uh products and for testing
as a former
uh or well in fact founder of the all
party group on life sciences before i
became a minister
i can attest to that i'm hoping to be
called for a vaccine in the next couple
of weeks myself and if it's astrozenica
i will happily take it in my arm
minister thank you so much for speaking
to us
and good luck with your vaccine thank
you thank you
well joining me now is our political
correspondent joe pike uh what did you
make of
what the minister had to say there first
of all jennifer no i don't think it's
unsafe scientists tell us
all as well uk unlikely i think to
follow seven other uh countries in
pausing their role out of that vaccine
of course the main news
around the the death of sarah everard
and the government's response to
violence against women and girls mr
morehouse saying the scenes on saturday
night and captain common were
distressing and alarming but i think
this review into what happened this
independent review into the police's
actions
will take the heat out of it certainly
everyone in government
all sources i've spoken to seem pretty
clear that crested dick has the prime
minister's
support will stay in a job and labour
are not calling for her to go
there did seem to be a slight admission
jillian that the
home secretary pretty patel has called
on
the police to sort of stop mass
gatherings because they are
illegal perhaps a suggestion that this
happened partly because
of the law that the government put into
place during the pandemic
i thought it was interesting also that
mr malthus said that violence against
women and girls
seems endemic in parts of our society
also he pointed out the number of
submissions to that survey
on this issue is now at 64 000 pounds
a new number so the events of the past
week have clearly
been a catalyst the government are
seemingly taking it seriously and we're
due to hear from the prime minister we
think later today yeah
look forward to that joe for the moment
thank you
well the prime minister will speak again
with the met police commissioner
later today as she resists calls so far
to resign emma birchley is outside new
scotland yard this morning for us
and emma um can you update us at all um
have we heard anything more
from the met commissioner
no the last we heard was yesterday when
she made it absolutely
clear that she would be going nowhere
cressida dick saying that
she was now more determined not less
to stay in her role leading the
metropolitan police
and that she welcomed an independent
review that's being carried out by the
inspectorate
of constabulary it's being described as
a lessons learnt
review and while she was making it clear
she wouldn't be resigning there were
protesters here
at new scotland yard furious at what
happened to sarah furious
about the way things unfolded
on saturday night with the police
response
to that vigil and they then moved around
to parliament square to carry on their
protests but what's quite clear is this
whole issue
is really gaining momentum there are
high-level political meetings we know
that police chiefs are meeting today to
talk about how best to
protect women in this country
and all of this on the day that the bill
is being debated
in the commons which has come under fire
for not doing enough not having enough
detail on how to
uh end violence against women and also
criticism
for um giving suggesting that police
should have more powers
um to clamp down on disruptive protests
and actually
that's one of the issues that protesters
are going to be back in parliament
square
protesting about from five o'clock today
they want to come
here to remember sarah to remember what
they call
victims of male violence but also
to stand up against this bill
uh restricting protests that can be
carried out by people like them
emma thank you
still to come on the show at half past
seven we're joined by the shadow
policing minister sarah jones
as labour calls for more government
action to tackle violence against women
at around half past eight uh we'll be
joined by one of the women who was
arrested at the vigil for sarah everard
patsy
stevenson and at a quarter
to eight uh the welsh health minister
born getting
joins us as it's uh back to school and
back to the hair salons
it started with an uprising which many
hoped would bring
democracy instead it plunged syria into
a 10-year long
civil war with the country's ruler
bashar al-assad
apparently victorious
across the 10 years 593 000 people have
been killed
according to figures from the uk-based
syrian observatory for human rights
of whom more than a hundred thousand
were civilians
the number detained is far harder to
account for after a ten-year-long
investigation
the un released a report earlier this
month putting the total in the tens of
thousands
that civilians arbitrarily detained in
syria and still
forcibly disappeared thousands more have
been subject
to torture sexual violence or death in
detention
syria remains the world's largest
refugee crisis with more than
13 million people displaced according to
the unhcr
more than 6.6 million of those have been
forced to flee
outside of syria with another 6.7
million displaced inside the country
and record 12.4 million syrians 60
percent of the country's population
now face hunger according to new data
from the un world food
programme that's the impact of the kovid
19 pandemic on top of already being worn
down
by a decade of conflict mark stone
reports from north eastern syria now
the story of syria this past 10 years
begins
and it ends with this man president
bashar al-assad
it is the story of an uprising against
him brutally suppressed by him
it's been a war which has changed our
understanding of brutality
it shifted politics well beyond its
borders
and it has left the country and its
people broken and divided
we're 400 miles from the capital
damascus
amudha is in the northeastern corner of
syria
and we're following muhammad from the
destroyed city of aleppo originally
but here now with his whole family
there are four generations here all 14
of them
sleep where we sit but it's better than
what they left
in one sense they are the lucky ones
they're in a house not a refugee camp
but then not being in a camp means they
don't have help from charities
the disintegration of a country at war
begins with the death
and the pain but beyond that are the
legacies
on the road east we pass a convoy of
trucks
a resupply chain for the american troops
who are here
these plains of northern syria are now
where the superpowers tussle for control
there's regional influence and oil to
secure
this is the only place in the world
where russian and american militaries
brush past each other
commissioning is a city like the country
divided
most of it under the control of the
kurds now but pockets are still assad's
land in the souk
money changers need carts to carry their
currency
because so much is needed to buy so
little
anything else
in a clamor for currency he is in demand
and spells out the crisis
the devaluation of course has a
devastating effect on salaries
is vice president of this region which
in the chaos
has declared itself autonomous
[Music]
[Music]
here after a decade of war is hard but
you can
find it on the faces of the young
who will pick up the pieces mark stone
sky news
in syria
the netherlands has become the seventh
country to suspend
use of the oxford astrazeneca
coronavirus vaccine
over concerns about possible side
effects the dutch government said the
move which will last for at least two
weeks was a precaution
after reports of blood clotting events
in adults in norway
the world health organization says
there's no link between the jab
and an increased risk of developing a
clot and the european medicines agency
insists the vaccine's benefits continue
to outweigh
its risks
primary schools will reopen to pupils
from all years in wales and scotland
from this morning
people in wales can get their hair cut
again if they have an appointment
it's the latest restriction to be lifted
as part of the nation's easing of
lockdown
the uk has recorded its lowest number of
deaths with covid19 since early october
4618 new cases have been recorded in the
latest 24-hour period
with another 52 deaths within 28 days of
a positive test
that takes the total number of victims
to 125
516 more than 24 million people have now
received a first dose
of a coronavirus vaccine
thousands of women have joined protests
in cities across australia
calling for gender equality and justice
for victims of sexual assault
the march for justice rallies were
established in the wake of sexual
assault allegations
within the australian parliament and
against former attorney general
christian porter
allegations he denies organizers held a
rally outside parliament
after rejecting a private meeting with
prime minister
scott morrison
time now to take a look at the weather
for you with uh naz and how's it looking
today you're smiling
[Laughter]
well yeah for most places it's actually
looking fine and settled today after
the recent wet and windy conditions
which is good news but there will be
some rain around in fact you can see a
little bit of rain behind me right now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning from midweek onwards we are
going to see largely dry
conditions for much of the uk island as
we head towards the weekend
however it will be becoming colder as
well but until then
there's still some wet weather to be had
but it's also
fairly mild we start off with mainly dry
and bright conditions but there is
cloudy skies and spells of rain across
parts of ireland and northern ireland at
the moment and that rain perhaps edging
to western parts of wales and southwest
of england through this morning too
then later through the day we will see
it to spread even further
uh eastwards towards western parts of
scotland where
there will be some heavier downpours
elsewhere there will be mainly dry and
bright conditions but cloud amounts will
increase through the day
so the sunshine will be turning hazy but
it won't be as windy as recently
and it will be mild the policing
minister kit malthouse has said
he doesn't back calls for the
metropolitan police commissioner to
resign
following criticism of the way the force
policed a vigil in memory of sarah
everard on
saturday i found it very distressing and
the pictures were obviously
alarming which is why the home
secretaries asked for this
independent investigation into what
actually
happened uh so that we can hold the
police accountable which i know they're
happy uh uh to be so um to make sure
that everything
was done in accordance with the rules do
you back calls that she should stand
down
no i don't and i do recognize that the
police are in an incredibly difficult
position i mean throughout this pandemic
we've asked them to do a job that
they've never done before and to
stand between the public if you like and
this terrible
virus in a way that none of us are used
to and certainly they aren't as well
um and so that very very difficult
position that they're in
uh needs to be reflected in our
contemplation of of this
let's speak now to the shadow minister
for policing sarah jones good morning to
you as we heard there the home secretary
has
called for an investigation into events
of saturday night
are you satisfied by that that they are
taking it seriously
well look i completely agree with the
minister that we need to
do this investigation into what happened
and that what we saw on saturday night
was alarming
and that we need to make sure we learn
the lessons but i completely disagree
with the minister's response to the
overarching issue here
which is that violence against women has
not been taken
seriously the government has not been
tough on crime for the last 10 years
and now is a chance to respond and a
response which involves
another strategy a meeting is just
not acceptable and we need to we need to
think about what happened on saturday
pause the legislation that is
uh introducing even more kind of loose
powers
for the government and for police on
protests but we need to keep at the
heart of this
sarah everard and the the tackling of
violence against women and girls that
thousands of women across the country
are now calling for
but the minister was saying that uh the
bill to be debated
in parliament will actually serve to add
more to
protections for for women in terms of uh
sexual harassment
potentially that could be um added into
the the legislation so actually
it's increasing government powers in
protecting women
so it's a 300-page bill not a single
mention of women
it is suggesting that if you um if you
do anything to a memorial um
you will get a 10-year sentence up to a
10-year sentence when
the minimum sentence for rape is five
years
you know we have a legal system where
you can get more uh
punishment for fly tipping than you can
for stalking
our rape conviction rates have plummeted
to the point where pretty much everyone
gets away with it
in one year there were 55 000
uh cases of rape reported to the police
less than one and a half thousand
ended in conviction this is really
bad and i think the outpouring from
women that we've seen
that we've all felt that sense of we're
not safe on our streets something needs
to be done about it
has to be responded to and the question
for government is will you join with us
cross party and putting a whole raft of
changes
to this legislation which we can do
so that we make the situation better for
once
for women but but the government is
saying that um
the police and crime sentencing courts
bill it's actually fulfilling manifesto
pledges
including tougher sentences for uh child
murderers
and sex offenders so what exactly are
you objecting to
we're objecting to it on two very
fundamental reasons the first is it does
absolutely nothing to tackle violence
against
women and the second is it includes uh
measures on protest which we need to
pause
and reflect about and i think a lot of
people will agree with that i've been
talking to the police
a lot about these issues of course we
feel for those officers who are trying
to
uh do the right thing when it comes to
these kind of decisions but we need to
have a conversation about what rights
people should have and what powers the
police and the government should have
but at its heart
this is an opportunity for change and of
course there are things in the bill
that we've been campaigning for for for
a long time i mean
we really wanted emergency um uh workers
who were assaulted to have
uh their their their the people who
assault them to have a longer sentence
we've been calling for that
for years um so there are some things in
there that are good so
we're voting against it at this stage
because of those missed opportunities
and because of the protest
um clauses we want to make this better
in committee
the government now has an opportunity to
do that with us
cross party respond to those women
because we need to do it now
and if not now when another meeting
another strategy
is not what we need after 11 years of
going in the wrong direction
why not back the bill then and include
the areas where
you feel it it's lacking so that
progress can be made because from what
you're saying
you don't disagree with the bill it's an
entirety at all do you
no we don't that's absolutely right the
parliamentary process
is that today and tomorrow we have a
debate on
the bill in its entirety and we either
vote for it or we vote
against it we then go into committee and
i'll be overseeing the home office kind
of elements on behalf of the labour
party for that so we vote against it now
because it's doing nothing for women
and uh uh understand the process
understand the process what i don't
understand is
why you don't back the bill in the
initial stage and then
move forward with amendments and have
the the areas that you want included
added on
because this is a perfectly normal way
to respond to a piece of legislation
that has significant flaws
we can't support it in its current state
um but we hope we can amend it in uh
in committee and we hope that we can get
to a point where we can support it
as it goes through all its all its
changes but but we must remember
sarah everard tackling violence against
women this is what women across the
country
are telling us they want us to do and in
parliament we have to respond to that
and coming back to to the vigil for
sarah everardo on saturday evening
and the police handling of that do you
believe that
crested dick should resign i think
there's going to be an investigation
the mayor of london said that he was
given assurances that uh the the the
vigil would be policed
sensitively and something clearly went
wrong and we need to understand what
that is
you know i want to pay tribute to our
police officers who have worked
so hard in this year and on the whole
got that balance right in in
what was incredibly complex emergency
legislation
but but something went wrong on saturday
and we need to work out what that
is um but we mustn't let that side track
us
from the bigger issue which is that
women wanted to pay their respects to
sarah everard we saw kate middleton
doing it earlier in the day
because even she understood the fear um
even she has experienced um that sense
that we're not safe on our streets and
we
that's what we have to respond to but
somebody does have to to take
responsibility uh should krista dick
resign
that's that's not the question for today
we need to have that
independent inquiry because we don't
know the answers as to what went wrong
we just know something went wrong
but we need to try and work out what
that was there were police forces across
the country that were trying to deal
with this situation because lots of
women
wanted to have a vigil and the fact that
there wasn't an agreement come to when
the
when the judges said that the vigil
would not be unlawful if they could come
to an agreement about how it could be
done in a covered safe way
that opportunity was missed and and we
need to look at why and what happened
so does the commissioner have your
backing to stay in post
she she is going to be um
along with all the questions about what
happened on saturday
investigated in terms of what went wrong
and we need those answers it's not right
for us to look at pictures where
something clearly went wrong but but to
not know what happened operationally to
lead up to that point
we have to understand that before we
throw um
comments around about who should resign
and who shouldn't resign but we have to
keep in mind
tackling violence against women and
pausing this bit of legislation on
protests because
the key point is what happened on
saturday needs to be a one-off
not something that becomes normal indeed
as shadow minister for policing though
i'm just really trying to establish
whether
the commissioner does have your backing
to remain in post
well i'll say again that this is
a situation that needs to be
investigated i am not going to
you don't feel you don't feel able to
back her then
look i back the police i know they've
had an incredibly difficult situation
we need some answers as to what happened
and i know that you know i agree with
her with the policing minister
on his approach i agree uh with the
mayor of london on his approach to this
which is let's get the answers before we
start
throwing around um uh calls for people
to resign or not to resign
i think we need the answers we need to
learn we need to learn the specific
lessons
but also we need to keep our eye on that
wider question of what we're going to do
about the fact that if you get raped the
chances of your perpetrator being
convicted
are about 1 and that is completely
unacceptable
and we need to do something about that
okay sarah jones thank you very much for
speaking to us
shadow minister for policing and the
fire service thank you
now people in wales will be able to get
a haircut
for the first time in 2021 today if they
have an appointment
as hairdressers and barbers reopen the
change marks the first lifting of
coronavirus rules
primary school pupils also return to
classrooms
and i'm joined now by vaughn gethin
welsh health minister
good morning to you um bring us up to
date with the easing of
lockdown just run us through what people
can now do
from today well as you described more of
our children will be back to school
today that means
all the primary school and exam years in
secondary school that's years 11
and 13 but also with some flexibility
for schools to bring like years 10 and
12 and then have check-ins with
younger students in secondary school
hairdressers
open from today and then from next week
we'll have non-essential retail in
supermarkets primarily being open and
then we'll be following
we'll then see self-contained up the
first part of our tourism sector
we'll then see the rest of non-essential
retail opening on the 12th of april when
that laws will be the case in england
and are you confident that people will
um
respect these new measures now that the
easing of lock down
are you worried that you might see a
spike in
infections well we're as confident
as we can be but the reality is until we
start easing these measures we
we can't have a definitive prediction
and advance the population response
but the reason why lockdown rates are
low in wales they're under 40 cases in a
hundred thousand
today that is because of the population
response and it's also because the
impact of the successful vaccination
program as well
so our message to the public is we want
to see these events made as quickly and
as safely as possible
we're doing them in a phase way so we
can understand the impact of each
easement
but please for all the progress all of
the sacrifice we've made please let's
not blow it now
and make sure that as we have these new
freedoms we're still all doing the right
thing to keep all of us safe
sounds like you've got a full-legged
friend who's easy to uh break out
himself there in the in the background
um
people obviously lots of people
suffering and fatigue of
living under uh lockdown and suffering
through these
restrictions and are you worried at all
though that people might
go further than what's being allowed at
the moment
it's always a concern whenever we ease
the rules that some people go beyond
them
and that's part of what we have to try
to factor in to understand where we are
but we know having a phased approach to
understand what the impact is
on transmission but also the broader
population response whether people will
live within the new parameters that
we're setting to try to give back
successfully
freedoms on a sustained basis well
that's part of what we're trying to do
we're doing it in a context where the
kent variant is now dominant
and our advice is up to 70 percent more
transmissible
than the previous dominant strain of
coronavirus so each step
comes with more risk about a potential
return to higher coronavirus rates
the vaccination program can give us more
confidence about our ability to protect
the most vulnerable people
but if we do go out too fast then it's
entirely possible to see significant
harm coming into our hospitals
so this is still a matter of all of us
trying to do the right thing together
but
since we went into lockdown before
christmas the overall response from the
public here in wales
has been fantastic in the way that the
great majority people have done the
right thing
that's what we need to see more of to
make sure we successfully ease our way
out of this lockdown
and was sustainable path for the rest of
this year
what are your plans for easing
restrictions further
what's the the next stage what will you
next be looking forward to
well we'll then be considering as we get
towards the end of april
whether it'll be possible to have a
household mixing but but the stage
before that
is on the 12th of april we'll then have
all schools fully returning
so that's quite a big deal in having
every student back
in a classroom so we need to see the
impact of that and then to consider
whether further reasons can be made
after that
so we need to have a gap of several
weeks after school is open to understand
the impact of that
that's when we can consider whether
household mixing could change
or the gyms could start whether out the
hospitality could start
but all of this heavily caveated on what
happens with this current set of
easements we've announced
the return to school on the 12th of
april and that remains our overriding
priority
not to compromise our ability to get all
of our children back to face to face
learning
so that's why we've got a relatively low
risk set of easements that are taking
place
now because if we do that successfully
we can then ask them confidence about
further
unlocking on a sustained basis through
the rest of the sun
well getting thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning good to see
you
thank you thank you
let's take a look at the weather for you
now with nas
and is it looking like a sunny day will
there be some sunshine
say yes
anything for you jillian yes there will
be some bright or sunny spells across
most places today and much drier
and less windy than it was recently too
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning from midweek onwards we are
going to see the weather settle down
with much drier conditions however
there will be some wet weather around
until then in fact for
today we are seeing rain across parts of
ireland northern ireland some showers
scattered across
northwest england down towards east
anglia in the southeast and the
northeast of scotland too
now the showers across most of britain
will clear away by this afternoon but
the cloudy skies and rain over ireland
and northern ireland will spread
eastwards
to western parts of britain later
elsewhere though mainly dry and bright
but a bit cloudier later